the so-called water tank of morocco the
middle atlas mountain range is
experiencing an unprecedented long
absence of snow complicating the
repercussions of a severe drought that
could impact the crop-importing nations
the slopes of mitchell finn's ski resort
and the habri mount region have not seen
snow for up to three and a half months
during their winter season this means
that rivers sourcing their water from
this northern region may not be able to
feed farms that are as far as 200 miles
away
the kingdom has pledged 1.1 billion in
aid for farmers who account for
one-third of the active workforce to
help them mitigate the repercussions of
the most severe drought to hit morocco
since 1981
the absence of snow has also affected
tourism in the area
there are far less tourists and school
trips for the resorts
foreign
locals believe morocco's water problems
will most likely get worse before they
get better as water intensive farming
lower precipitation and the effects of
climate change combined could further
reduce the kingdom's water capital
[Music]